it's Tuesday as good as a [ __ ]
gets beautiful people the sun's out the
birds are chirping your dip is hard what
the [ __ ] do you have to be depressed
about a complaint about it
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive you know why cuz you're [ __ ]
ready to go and guess what there ain't
nobody gonna stop it maybe Anthony
Weiner it was [ __ ] what's happened
you bad [ __ ] weevil Joey here
two more days left in a month are moving
a meet with people more legit zoos are
moving [ __ ] over making [ __ ] phone
calls don't cast the [ __ ] slight but
get some [ __ ] up with the chitty-chat
so I say it's gonna send them the man of
many business I still got this move
[ __ ] death on two legs
my buddies over there black leaf growing
some [ __ ] to the [ __ ] sand Atlanta
[ __ ] this Paris and this little Bri
that bill is not it's perennial is not
really [ __ ] not for any old G it's a
couple different mixes of [ __ ]
killers I put up [ __ ] dead I'm saying
nobody's getting ready for [ __ ] Labor
Day huh we're gonna make barbecue
[ __ ] chicken wings anyway swap all
the [ __ ]
you don't think I'm ready getting ready
for this foot today [ __ ] cuz
that's all that counts I'll give a [ __ ]
about Wednesday I don't give a [ __ ]
about Thursday Friday I don't give a
[ __ ] about next week it makes no
difference for me I love when people
come up with mini one this month I'm
gonna listen I don't give a [ __ ] about
next weekend damn well I worry man is in
the mouth today that's why the podcast
is called the church or what's happening
now today what have you done [ __ ]
today not lately I know last year you
hit the lottery for 8 million would you
do today today would you mom who's on a
date because did you write that you
write a [ __ ] story
did you [ __ ] love a Shriner but Joey
enough with the chitty-chat let's get
down [ __ ]
well something to my shish kebob this
here's my shish kebab stick this like
[ __ ] shish kebab ain't my [ __ ] just
like a fine samhsa's try this one out
first you see that this is about here
this is pure push something else I had
not Zilla just the bottom you know it
just gets [ __ ] drying at like 3
cataclysms riley them it's powder you
mix those things together and you
[ __ ] wait for your head explode this
bad after over right now
very
mateesah but bird'll it's my split that
motherfucker's going down
between the [ __ ] formed I nail the
THC limits anyone
I love it
let me tell you some of the big things
on Tuesdays can stay so definitely a
great place
[ __ ] man in my life and I was a kid
man I see how I don't like to get the
call Bleeker that means don't make big
[ __ ] moves on a Tuesday that you get
[ __ ] complicated you understand you
keep the load for you still back to put
them piece with you the chain shoot but
it's not a major league day you can't
move [ __ ] 20 kilos you know live the
dad got arrested for kidnapping I tried
to kidnap the bouton I don't think they
understand nothing play with Chris Brown
he's up this house right now
cops are all around them three hands
crying and everybody's gonna flop and
shoot this boy you don't come down on a
Tuesday good day you recover that's the
no penomet baldness it's kicking in the
[ __ ] gas this Mike smoking pigeon
[ __ ] you're gonna see some intervention
look at how I told you this [ __ ] I'm
smoking today this [ __ ] I'm talking the
[ __ ] I'm smoking today
forget about anyway I'm feeling good
I lost another [ __ ] pound last week
which I'm not very happy about listen
guys it's a little [ __ ] little goals
bro you know what we go to see a
football game and a team could come out
throw [ __ ] three 20-yard pass and
scored touchdown me I'm a [ __ ] old man
and a piece of [ __ ] I go four inches
because good inches I'm way out that's
what I've been doing [ __ ] all
my life we're in amount so they gotta
give me when I [ __ ] asked for I take
it from them that's the [ __ ] man Cal
you weren [ __ ] help you know Oh Jake
Anderson when he played for the Giants
that year he was 38 years old going on
50 little run three [ __ ] yards and
that's what they did they just get just
keep going for [ __ ] little yards
every day that's it let these dumb
[ __ ] go for the [ __ ] deep
threat and then they turn intersection I
gotta start from scratch but guys like
you a mate we don't throw interceptions
we can't you know why because it's a
game of [ __ ] inches and while they're
looking for the bottom over there look
over here making [ __ ] inches or
breaking it down I'll see you
[ __ ] on a Tuesday always go for
the inches does that go for the bottom
they get intercepted eventually we don't
do big we all not the ball off [ __ ]
head neither we go [ __ ] forward
everything take [ __ ] from nobody you do
bad of a [ __ ] and tap allow you
an American get up for the national
anthem [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
what you feel
[Music]
it's just a [ __ ] song still gotta get
up
State of Mind understand [ __ ] these
[ __ ] I know it is to be a
[ __ ] ever gonna come to this country
I'm the first one off my [ __ ] feet in
front of national
yeah
even though I'm a salad from the
freshmen off my feet man nationally most
normal of most vegetarian
to game and just people don't believe
nothing society much they think it's a
game of [ __ ] 30-yard fast
Dan Fouts everyone a [ __ ] Super Bowl
no cuz he was a quarry out always up in
the end look at the [ __ ] that
kept in the game inches everything doing
a game anxious eventually you'll hit
that line it might take you [ __ ] 10
years it might take you 20 years but
you're gonna [ __ ] hit it okay I'm
doing it right now I'm above luck in
three [ __ ] I'm a yard away from the
touchdown these [ __ ] don't even
know it they're over there talking to
other people me I'm gonna slip in nice
much
that's the [ __ ] plan of the
Tuesday I understand
grab your ball so look the flag and go
up and get what's yours concept is at
the end of the day it's more [ __ ]
news
the hardest thing is decide what not to
take flop these cops up the church might
be today might be tomorrow we don't
[ __ ] know but pay attention beside
that tomorrow night the Icehouse Friday
night the ice house two shows a Willie
Barcena and then the party starts in
Austin September 15th and we take you to
New York City September 24th captain and
beside that that's it go out there and
knock it down three inches you did your
[ __ ] job today stay black
uncle Joey loves you
and tell them all the suck it dick boy
it might be the gimmick in my my till I
being our I said he stay black
the other finishes boy I just can't
leave you with more birth that's not the
mood there's no management damage didn't
[ __ ] it
and that's it and that's back
have a good day we'll take no [ __ ] from
nobody stay black